boris johnson se disculpó ante el
parlamento británico en medio de los
llamados por su renuncia antes de que el
ahora conocido como parte gates saliera
a la luz el primer ministro se había
dirigido al parlamento negando haber
infringido las normas
pido disculpas una vez más a todos los
que perdieron a sus seres queridos en
particular a los que sufrieron durante
la pandemia y señor presidente me
declaración el tratado explicar por qué
hable a la cámara como lo hice
sin embargo el líder de la oposición se
tomó la disculpa de johnson como una
broma y lo acusó de querer desviar la
atención utilizando la guerra de ucrania
hasta lights es de broma incluso ahora
cuando la última falsa disculpa sale a
trompicones por un lado de su boca por
el otro lado no tan nuevas evasivas y
distorsiones pero el daño ya está hecho
el pueblo ha tomado una decisión y no
cree ni una palabra de lo que dice el
primer ministro
dayton felipe prominentes 6
en la tensa sesión parlamentaria johnson
criticó que la oposición se centrará en
ataques personales en vez de
concentrarse en la importancia del
conflicto ucraniano para los británicos
johnson se saltó las medidas de
prevención contra el coronavirus para
hacer una fiesta en junio de 2020 en la
residencia oficial down street y la
policía lo multó el jueves 21 de abril
los legisladores votarán si el primer
ministro debe ser investigado por las
denuncias de mentir al parlamento sobre
sus fiestas durante las cuarentenas